una renuncia que cayó por sorpresa al
ejecutivo nacional fuera de la ahora ex
secretaria de derechos humanos bernarda
ordóñez en una carta publicada remitida
al jefe de estado explicó que su
decisión era irrevocable y aseguró que
estaba motivada por la nueva visión
planteada por el gobierno nacional la
cual dista de sus objetivos iniciales al
asumir el cargo de construir un país de
oportunidades y encontrarnos por los
derechos expresó la ex funcionaria del
gobierno de guillermo lasso bernardo
ordóñez manifestó diferencias con el
gobierno cuando se produjeron incidentes
con la policía nacional en las marchas
por el día internacional de la mujer
donde éstas denunciaron hechos violentos
en su contra mientras se manifestaban a
favor de derechos la postura del
presidente fue solidarizarse con los
cuerpos del orden mientras que bernarda
ordóñez demandó investigaciones y
explicaciones a los cuerpos de seguridad
aseguró que se pronunció como ciudadana
en sol y agrega con las mujeres en
contra de tratos sufridos en
manifestaciones por el día internacional
de la mujer también reprochó el manejo
de la crisis carcelaria en el país y la
violencia en contra de mujeres y niñas
la ex secretaria de derechos humanos fue
la responsable de la creación de la
eliminación del iva en productos de
higiene menstrual femenina en el aumento
del presupuesto para la atención de la
población indígena huaorani la firma del
decreto del bono de femicidio y mayores
casas de acogida y centro de atención
para mujeres víctimas de violencia